nos piden resolver y graficar la
solución del sistema de ecuaciones que
tenemos aquí y lo primero que se me
ocurre es que podemos eliminar una de
las variables si nos fijamos en la x
aquí tenemos 4x y aquí tenemos 2 x al
sumar las ecuaciones tal cual están nos
daría 6 x eso no las eliminaría pero si
multiplicamos este 2x por menos 2 nos va
a dar menos 4x y al sumarlo con 4x se
van a cancelar las x hagamos eso
multipliquemos esta ecuación esta
segunda ecuación x menos 2 voy a
multiplicar ambos lados de esta ecuación
x menos 2 y la razón de esto es que este
2x se convierte en menos 4x para
eliminarlo con el 4x de arriba pero
tengo que multiplicar por menos 2 todos
los términos del lado izquierdo y del
lado derecho para que no se altere la
igualdad así es que la segunda ecuación
se transforma en menos 4 x menos 2 x 2 x
4 x menos 2 x menos más 2 lo cual es
igual a 2.5 por menos 2 menos 5 esto es
simplemente la segunda ecuación x menos
2 y voy a escribir debajo la primera
ecuación
4 x 2 igual a 5 y voy a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones y ahora ya podemos eliminar
al sumar menos 4x con 4x se van a
cancelar sumemos entonces estas dos
ecuaciones vamos a sumar lado izquierdo
con lado izquierdo y lado derecho con
lado derecho y lo podemos hacer porque
estos dos son iguales estamos haciendo
lo mismo a ambos lados de la ecuación y
que nos queda si sumamos menos 4x con 4x
esto se cancela nos va a dar 0 0 podemos
poner inclusive 0 x se fueron las x
ahora si sumamos 2 jay menos 2 y también
vamos a obtener 00 y y esto va a ser
igual a menos cinco más cinco también es
cero que está pasando estamos obteniendo
una ecuación que es ser igual a cero que
sucede aquí si bien esto es cierto
también es un poco bizarro teníamos xy
es en la ecuación y ahora todo todo se
ha cancelado vamos a explorar esto vamos
a graficar estas ecuaciones para ver qué
es lo que quiere decir esta ecuación se
da igual a cero que hemos obtenido
déjame graficar esta ecuación
la voy a hacer en azul se encuentra en
forma estándar la voy a llevar a la
forma pendiente ordenada voy a describir
la ecuación aquí es 4 x menos 2 es igual
a 5 podemos restar 4x a ambos lados
quiero despejar la y entonces que
tenemos estos términos se van nos queda
menos 2 es igual a menos 4 x + 5
ahora vamos a dividir entre menos 2
entre menos 2 ambos lados de la ecuación
estos se cancelan nos queda ya que es
igual a menos 4 entre menos 2 esto es 2
x este término es 2 menos 2.5 menos 2.5
vamos a graficar esta ecuación la
ordenada al origen es menos 2.5 menos
uno menos dos menos 2.5 está el orden al
origen y la pendiente es 2 si avanzamos
1 en la dirección positiva si avanzamos
1 a la derecha
tenemos que subir 2 1 2 si avanzamos
otro a la derecha volvemos a subir 2 y
ahí tenemos
voy a trazar la recta lo mejor posible
es la parte más difícil de este tipo de
problemas trazamos la recta ya la
tenemos es la ecuación de arriba ahora
déjame graficar la ecuación de abajo y
lo voy a hacer en este color verde la
ecuación de abajo es
2x menos igual a 2.5
ahora vamos a restar 2x a ambos lados de
la ecuación que nos queda se cancelan
estos términos en x menos y es igual a 2
x + menos 2x más bien más 2.5 vamos a
multiplicar o dividir entre menos 1 nos
queda y es igual a 2x menos 2.5 vamos a
graficar esta ecuación ojo quizás ya te
diste cuenta de algo interesante la
ordenada el origen es menos 2.5 menos
2.5 y la pendiente es 2 es decir tenemos
exactamente la misma recta exactamente
la misma recta ya sólo obtuvimos
algebraica mente cuando pusimos las
ecuaciones en su forma punto pendiente
esta es la primera ecuación en forma
punto pendiente que coincide con esta
que es la segunda ecuación así es que la
identidad 0 igual a 0 nos está diciendo
que ambas ecuaciones representan a la
misma recta el sistema de hecho tiene
una infinidad de soluciones cualquier
punto sobre esta recta
responde a ambas ecuaciones va a
satisfacer el sistema si me das un valor
de y arbitrario obtengo el valor de x en
la ecuación de arriba y esa pareja x va
a cumplir con la ecuación de abajo así
es que el sistema tiene una infinidad de
soluciones es una sola recta